okay three two one hello everybody and
welcome to the pretty little kitty
podcast what fill him with love do I
want to do this he was not suspicious
because Bob was withholding information
the whole damn time and literacy oh you
thought you could dodge me there one go
Dick Cheney joke that Dick Cheney being
killed by Sarah Palin today mooses
coming soon Putin that's Putin the Vice
in vice president don't laugh she's
watching you Putin from her backyard yep
I gots to paddle get you
who's the shark now ah there we go
alright I got my buddy here you're gonna
be my only friend in the whole wide
world
no no no no God when I'm an apocalyptic
situation I prefer I prefer to throw
things in their face that are metal and
going about 500 miles an hour
pretty go where do you all around the
back door the exact same place I should
have killed them tiny bugs Tim needs to
be rescued or something rather Bob and
Wade I forgot that my face was in the
middle of melting
bring it on you [ __ ] [ __ ] and
douches I'm not sure which one I
actually when you start insulting people
instead of calling him a douche or a
[ __ ] call them I'm gonna die over and
over again it's gonna be bad I'm not
gonna do anything but you guys wouldn't
yell at me right cuz you're all
beautiful adorable awesome intelligent
crazy great gamer people and you're
awesome and I believe in you and you are
the best whoa where the hell's my raft
this love shotgun I have a love shotgun
I'm shooting them oh god hates figs okay
that's an interesting take that I see
Bob's name that's weird what I see I'm
invincible I'm not
thanks for watching all of the videos in
this compilation are available in the
description so check them out and if
you'd like to see more in the future
please leave a like to let me know if
you enjoyed this video and you'd like to
see more on a daily basis please
subscribe today or if you're already
subscribed share this video with a
friend thanks again for watching and
I'll see you in the next video bye bye